foreign
[Music]
thank you
when I do count the clock that tells the
time
and see the brave day sunk in hideous
night
when I Behold The Violet
past prime and Sable curls or silver
door with white
when the lofty trees I see Aaron of
leaves which asked from heat to canopy
the herd and Summer's green all girded
up in sheaves
born on the beer with white and bristly
beard
then of thy Beauty do I question Luke
that thou among the wastes of time must
go
since sweets and Beauties do themselves
forsake
and die
as fast as they see others grow
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
God
foreign
[Music]
and nothing against times Scythe can
make defense
save breed
to Brave him when he takes the hints
thank you
[Music]